both of you your performances
in this film you had to give so much of
yourself and there
um and i'm curious what was it like for
each of you when sam pulled you aside
and said okay so
we've shot for two days but yeah i'm not
going to use any of that
[Laughter]
listen i know sam very very well and by
the look of his face and marcel's face
i knew it was coming so i was not
surprised
um but you know what i found out there
both times
both times i could see the stressful
looks
um but you know what i think
because i think we all um
were invested in this in such a huge way
and are also supportive and this really
was a safe space like
i think we all knew and we're so
grateful to be there anyway i do
it however many times we needed to do it
because i i just
enjoyed being there with john david and
and saying
what we were saying and i it was a dream
for me so i would
do it as many takes as we needed to i
would say the same thing it was actually
because it's
because though it was very lengthy you
know in dialogue
uh rhythmically it it benefited us to
to con you know to do it more time so
getting to revisit it
uh with it in my spirit having done it
already i imagine like being on stage
and doing a broadway play or something
like the more times you do it
the more confident you are about it the
more discoveries that happen
so yeah i thought you know you have it
you get rid of it at the
at the end of the day because you think
you're moving on because we're shooting
other scenes if we go back
but there was something that i can just
jump right into it because
you know a whole bunch of trial and
error stuff that happened the day before
so i i
and that in what zendaya was saying i
just loved being there i mean it was in
the middle of a daggone pandemic
we did everything safely and carefully
but yet here we are
doing what we love to do not knowing if
i'd ever get to do this again
how it would look i wasn't even i didn't
even know if anybody was going to see
this thing if
this even was going to get released or
whatever but you know what we're doing
something that we
truly truly believe in that is such a
unique unique twisted
uh love story that uh i would have done
it a whole bunch of times
yeah one of the things in the movie your
characters are checking
social media to um see you know the
reviews
of the film and i am curious for each of
you uh
are you checking social media after you
like the world premiere of a movie that
you're in
or do you try to like push away from all
of that to
you know what i mean like just ignore i
like to think that i could push it away
but i'm
too i'm too nosy i want to know you know
um
but i i will say that uh you know i do
have to manage it you know in the in the
same way you do everything in moderation
you know
um so i gotta i i try to find a balance
you know i want to see things but i also
don't want to be like glued to my phone
and like
having massive anxiety you know so
there's there's a way
to balance it and i also think that both
of us maybe handle reviews a little bit
differently
than malcolm would so i like to think
our response would be a little bit
different
you guys as i said at the beginning you
have to give so much of yourself each of
you to this role
what was it like actually at the end of
each day were you leaving set just
absolutely exhausted can you each talk
about that
yeah uh exhausted but yet uh enthused as
well because it felt like
we we really made something from the
ground up i know we all we'd all
together walk as a group to the car
sun was up you know like we shot nights
and it just felt like uh you know
victory every morning you know which was
the end of our day
uh that we're on to something that we're
just we're chipping away at something
that could be
super special extremely um special so um
it was a beautiful joyous you know
victorious kind of feeling
um that uh i actually always remember
those moments so every morning
which was the end of our days uh uh on
that shoot because it just felt like uh
we were getting closer to our goal
some days i mean like i said were harder
than others but i was so grateful
to be working and to be doing something
i was proud of
and you know even some days i'd go home
and
watch the dailies from the day before
and you know and
go through them just because i i was so
excited to be there i mean
you have to understand you know we're
living in such a difficult time and
there's so many people that were
um you know have been affected this past
year so the fact that we were able
to work do it safely and take care of
our crew that was also
with us on euphoria i think that was uh
i was so grateful to be working and to
be able to make something that could you
know positively affect these people that
i love and i care about
um and so i i was like probably the
opposite of everyone else i was like
we can keep going you know like the
sun's coming up and i'm like i feel
great
like you know i mean end of the 14
straight days and i was like i mean i
could keep going everybody's like i
think we're done
you know what i mean i had a ridiculous
amount of energy pent up you know
um so i like i said extremely grateful
to be there
thank you both so much congrats you're
both fantastic in the movie have a
fantastic day
thank you so much youtube